another thing I want to touch on is that
Aaron Hernandez doc was so stupid and
people in this country are so incredibly
stupid that when everyone was like it's
mind blowing you have to watch it it's
so mind-blowing the people in the
documentary are so dumb Aaron Hernandez
of course is the these guys a closeted
gay guy who kills the guy or whatever
you know is and everybody was like in
the documentary they're like how could
he do it
how could he killed someone and then he
goes in place of football it's like he
hey idiot athletes kill people we know
this none of it's fascinating
we know this they kill people they beat
people
they beat their wives I can't believe
he's sad at all in front of them I can't
believe we do this yeah rich people kill
people all the time how is this shocking
when you hear that that's mind blowing
and then you watch the documentary you
realize how [ __ ] we are as a country
we don't learn any lessons here we're
like goldfish in this country we have no
memory we cannot retain any piece of
information we start at zero every
[ __ ] day here I can't believe you
watch that documentary all these people
like it doesn't make any sense
he's successful and rich and you just
killed somebody how does it happen and
then he goes in plays football like it
didn't happen yeah yeah that's what
people do I don't understand what's
shocking about it it's just so sad what
what election I mean there's 20,000
arenas 20,000 seat arena is being filled
up so people can watch puppet shows what
election folks is gonna help here I mean
I'm trying to I mean I don't understand
there's 20,000 people to file in an
arena to see two puppets argue with each
other I'm not throwing you know whatever
you could fill in who the comic is
they're they're making a lot of money a
lot more than me but when you see 20,000
people laughing hysterically at a puppet
what what do you think it's gonna be
look like here what country do you think
we're living in are you aware of where
we are and who's in little houses and in
the cars I mean they want it look at
puppets they want to listen to puppets
argue with each other
puppet shows or what I liked when I was
three when I was three years old I
thought puppet shows were fun because
there was a little thing in my school
was a puppet theater and the little
puppet came up out of the Little Theater
and they had a fun show I got over that
by three and a half I was done with it I
said I don't like puppet shows anymore
because I bought puppets your parents
would get your puppets this is what
happened this is the natural reaction if
you're not good if your mind has not
been completely like shattered you get
the puppy you buy the puppets you play
with the puppets for a few hours you go
this kind of sucks I get it it's a
puppet and then you're done and then you
move on but there are large swathes of
the population millions and millions of
people who still enjoy a puppet him so I
mean I'm gonna try to sound would be
better than people I don't to be that
guy but at a certain point when
everybody's like you politics you have
all these people are doing the debate
we're gonna structurally reform the what
they're watching puppet shows how this
country doesn't have a dictator already
is it amazing I'm amazed that we don't
have a dictator already with what people
where where people are mentally in this
country people are mentally
broke it in this country their minds are
broken if they've been polluted with
sugar and fat and drugs and booze and
cheap entertainment
and they like puppet shows you would
talk to him about climate change have
the puppet to it I mean I mean have a
puppet moderate to debate it folks I
don't know what you think is gonna
happen
good listen Bernie Trump good whatever
Bernie's got great points I'm a big fan
of people having health insurance I
really am I know some people are you
upset at me about that I also on the
other flip side don't know if he'll be
able to get it done I know we're where
we're living you know I know in order to
get anything done in this country's got
to go into the woods and convince him to
a bunch of people in hoods in the middle
of the forest it's a good idea you know
you've got to convince a bunch of people
barbecuing human beings you know that
it's a good idea that we keep for
existing conditions in and I know that
can be challenging but I also deeply
skeptical of the ability for change
because I'm I've met people and I've
spoken to the people and I just don't
know you know what yeah you know I mean
I remember I was I was in rehab with a
kid and I've talked about this before we
got out of rehab and he invited me to
his girlfriend's house or his house his
girlfriend was there and he wanted to
watch the Jeff Dunham special now III
think Jeff is talented I've never met
Jeff you know all the disclaimers said
whatever you know who cares and [ __ ]
Jeff Don I'm like well I'm gonna go on a
road we just on him I'm gonna open up I
dressed up like a big puppet talk about
Disney kidnapping you kids I don't think
that's gonna fly but I'll give all the
disclaimers you know Jeff's great he's
got a lot of money's talented whatever
God loved him God God you know
boo bah boo they wanted me to watch a
Jeff Dunham special and they said our
favorite puppet is peanut and I said
what so I didn't really know I knew
Jefferson's ventriloquist but I didn't
know like I didn't know people got that
invested in the puppet I thought it was
maybe like dirty puppet chit like dark
puppet you could have fun with puppets
right I guess I don't know
but when I went to this house and I
watched it with them and I watched how
excited they were getting in there go
and when Jeff brought a peanut they went
nuts to sort of clapping on the couch I
said you I looked at this kid knowing
you should do heroin like you should go
back to doing drugs that was probably a
better life for you than sitting here
and having your mind numbed and they
just laughed so hard at this puppet and
I realized that for most people life
like for most people a lot of human
beings out there I don't know how many
people let's just say far too many okay
for far too many people life is a bowel
movement you know it's just like the
AIDS they don't have they just are
existing on earth and they don't think
too much about anything going on around
them they don't have the mental faculty
to comprehend what is going on they do
not understand what is happening and
then the people that do have those
mental faculties and do understand
what's happening tend to poison everyone
else and the reason for that is because
they meet them like the bushes the
Clintons they meet all the people
they're gonna shake their hands they do
all these events and ago yeah they're
watchin puppet shows so why not kill
people poison people
star wars you know these people watching
peanut I mean so
I mean I'm not trying to say we don't
have a lot of bright people here but the
average American like the average
American and this is why I could never
run for anything that in my past and
present future but the reason I could
never run for anything is because I go
do average American is the problem like
the average American who wants to watch
the puppet show and and just and just
like they just I mean you look at the
people that are on a cruise ship and
they just want to eat and just float
they just want to eat and fart and float
that's what a cruise is it's a bunch of
disgusting people that want to just [ __ ]
on a boat and watch garbage comedians
garbage music garbage entertainment
stuff their faces with food pulling this
important go buy a knick-knack go home
and put it on the refrigerator okay and
then go watch a puppet show I mean give
him free college they're not gonna go
they won't go we need to force him to go
would have gun to their head you can put
the military you're gonna drive them in
trucks give him free give them
everything
cancel the student debt cancel it
do what you want I you know peope they
don't want enough people just talk they
don't care they don't they don't even
know why there no one knows why they're
on earth so like the idea that most
people are gonna try to waste any time
figuring out anything they just go
they shrug you just want to feel things
your minds are dislocated from their
bodies they're impressed by light shows
you go to Vegas you sit down a
restaurant they got light shows
everybody yeah yeah I went to a
restaurant in Vegas there was a frog
singing and it's like it is something
fun about it cuz you're in Vegas but
like this is what people want they want
the puppets that's why politics is a
puppet show they're all puppets people
are water or politicians puppets is it
because you like actual puppets you like
actual puppets so why wouldn't the
politicians be puppets I mean fast cars
we like to see cars drive fast the
gooferz your call go first like to see
people beat the [ __ ] out of each other
you know that's it just what it is you
just you want to see porn where people
are beaten within an inch of their life
strangled choked defecated on you can't
common less Bloods being drawn you don't
I mean this is what people are doing out
there they're eating cinnamon roll
pancakes at Denny's or 1900 calories I
get it they're eating salted caramel
banana cream pancakes that doesn't even
sound good
serve with a pitcher you've been reading
on the patron episode serve with a
pitcher of caramel pitcher not a side a
picture of it you could drown your
pancakes and caramel and then go see the
puppets
[Laughter]